south korea practiced a missile strike
on north korea overnight after what
appears to be the north's largest ever
nuclear weapons test the u.s is
threatening the possibility of
overwhelming retaliation to any threat
south korea says the north's kim jong-un
may now be planning another long-range
missile test the u.n security council is
holding an emergency meeting this
morning to discuss the crisis north
korea claims sunday's nuclear test
brings it one step closer to attacking
the u.s mainland ben tracy is in seoul
where millions of south koreans live in
range of north korean artillery ben good
morning
good morning the south korean defense
ministry says it is closely monitoring
what it believes could be another
potential north korean missile launch
this could coincide with a major holiday
that takes place in north korea next
weekend but in the meantime the south
has responded to north korea's sixth
nuclear test quickly and fiercely
south korea brought out its military
might launching missiles in a dramatic
show of force designed to simulate an
attack on north korea's nuclear
facilities
it happened just hours after north
korean state television triumphantly
announced that kim jong-un's regime
tested a hydrogen bomb something it
called a perfect success
the blast at north korea's main nuclear
test site created a man-made earthquake
felt in china and russia
scientists believe it was potentially 10
times more powerful than north korea's
last nuclear test and at least five
times the explosive power of the bombs
the united states dropped on hiroshima
and nagasaki at the end of world war ii
it is a qualitatively different test
jonathan [ __ ] is an expert on north
korea's weapons program it is a not only
a much more powerful weapon but it might
also have been something that is more
miniaturized in other words so that it
would in theory
at least be able to fit on the warhead
of a long-range missile
just before the nuclear test north korea
released these pictures of kim jong-un
inspecting what the north claims is a
miniaturized hydrogen bomb the regime
says it could be placed on an
intercontinental ballistic missile
capable of reaching the united states
north korea successfully tested two
icbms in july
this is the highest priority for kim
jong-un he is wrapped up in this to an
extraordinary extent far beyond what i
would have imagined he he would have
done a year or two ago
south korea has also announced that it
will allow the u.s to install four more
thaad rocket launchers that's part of a
controversial missile defense system
here in south korea dana ben tracy in
seoul thank you